[Musique]
tout est
gelé voiture
je viens on vous dit c'est une
renaissance une autre naissance en fait
ouais bon
en fait toujours ouais mais
j'étais déprimé en fait j'avais la tête
j'avais la dépression et
quand j'ai rencontré la l'empathie et
j'ai commencé à parler doucement en fait
petit à petit et je trouvais dans mon
oreille en fait j'en avais bon écoutez
je les considère comme des familles
parce que ma vie omar m'avaient
accompagné pendant les moments les plus
difficiles
c'est c'était le mort foetale et les
moments les plus joyeux c'était
l'arrivée de mes de mes filles
com
[Musique]
même si elles sont bien entourés on ne
peut pas les mamans ne peuvent pas tout
dire ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
ressentait ce qu'elle pense la
culpabilité est donc extrêmement
présente c'est ya pas une maman qui qui
ne se dit pas mais qu'est ce que j'ai
fait qu'est-ce que j'ai pas fais
peut-être j'ai fait j'ai trop de travail
et peut-être je me suis trop fatigué il
ya quelque chose qui va pas en moi être
compris ça n'a rien d'évident un pur
pour ces mamans puisque l'entourage au
sens large et pas toujours pas toujours
compréhensifs
[Musique]
cette augmentation ne sait pas
actuellement l'expliqué mimouni les
autorités d'ailleurs ce qui veut dire
que personne ne suivait ça attentivement
sur les dernières années là c'est un
dénombrement de décès mais maintenant il
faut retourner au dossier et comme si
beaucoup de dossiers survêtement
complexe à faire pour essayer de
comprendre qu est-ce qui étaient
évitables qu'est ce qui n'était pas
évitable
[Musique]
on
on reçoit énormément de familles
endeuillées dans la période périnatale
depuis 99 quand on a ouvert cet
accompagnement
n'augmente nos partenariats et donc on a
de plus en plus de familles qui nous
sont orientés l'accompagnement des
familles endeuillées a pour objectif
d'éviter de prévenir les effets
délétères de la perte d'un enfant on
accompagne à la fois les parents mais
aussi la fratrie et on accompagne la
grossesse qui suit
on a un tiers de la population
seine-saint-denis sous le seuil de
pauvreté la pauvreté entraîne des
situations aussi de mauvaise qualité de
prise en charge d'une hygiène de vie ou
d'accès d'accès à la santé il serait
intéressant pour l'ensemble des familles
d'acteurs qui interviennent dans ce
domaine d'avoir quelque part une mise à
jour de l'ensemble des facteurs ça nous
aiderait nous en seine saint denis a
encore plus affiné les réponses que l'on
pourra apporter
[Musique]